but then Miranda you are one of those
rare people you genuinely liked school
loved school and it just sounded like it
was kind of version of st. Trinian's you
were proper it won't be stock hockey
sticks
Pakistan yeah I love lacrosse played
lacrosse loads and I loved school I like
the structure I like the fun we had girl
no no I was quite naughty and it sort of
very embarrassing silly way you had all
the little nicknames for each other was
your nickname
well my nickname is man and man the
sperm I was incredibly thin an
incredibly lanky and it was an all-girls
boarding school and so I said could we
change it to man so I got away with man
but all the nicknames at boarding
schools are ridiculous
it's all sort of Buffy important we had
something called puddle bully piss the
public piss of the nicknames for the
same reason no I don't know why she was
called pincer did a wife school puddle
that's crazy [__] sort of 25 years late
and you forget
[Music]
[Applause]
who's in my primary school who I won't
name who was called khaki because he
shot himself in I was called table top
because the head teacher put me on the
table because he saw me throwing a
girl's pants across the classroom to
humiliate me put me on the table and I
wet myself so I was called table top and
he was called Kathy and whenever I
walked past him he would go I would
reciprocate we had a school reunion
recently and I hadn't seen him for
thirty years as I was walking into the
pub I saw he was at a cash point and I
knew it was him and I went
[Music]
[Applause]
I was trying to have a penis bang on the
door it was blank aside from one
sentence that she's written on it which
was of the reasons why you think he
should be Teacher of the Year and she'd
written he's a well good laughs and he
don't make us do no work